so since you were here a couple months
ago you got an Oscar nomination we knew
it was gonna happen
how did you find out that's really cool
news watching the broadcast at home
really in the morning
um there was a knock at the door of my
bedroom and my kids were there with
balloons and they had a Carvel ice cream
cake oh my God I will cry right now
that's so sweet it was um fudgy the
whale
ice cream cakes are good oh yes yeah
enjoyed that one then now it's a core
memory of mine I love that I love are
you getting prepared for a speech do you
prepare speeches or do you are you
superstitious fail to prepare prepare to
fail oh well I'm the first one I'm gonna
put something in mind keep it behind
yeah glass with a little hammer on it
okay of emergency and then I'll be able
to thank all my people I like this help
get me where I need to be speaking of
boards you got an amazing bowling trophy
that we replenished for you so has it
found a really cool place in your home
yeah it's actually in the offices of a24
right now okay perfect I just think it
should go right next to your Oscar I'll
have them send it along I want you I
want you to put it right next to the
Oscar because
um so you you also this was interesting
you worked with a dance instructor for
the yeah uh Beth Lewis is a dance
instructor who danced a clubless company
for like seven or eight years wonderful
knowledge of the human body and because
uh Charlie is created with prosthetic
makeup and appliances
um it was it was a cumbersome uh costume
appropriately
um and to
drive home the reality of who he is and
what it's like to live with that she
would be in strict observation of
keeping a momentum to his every motion
to
um teaching me how to walk and observing
um gestures and it was very important
that we have such specificity because up
until now the the use of this costuming
in films and makeup has always been to
my mind in service of a mean joke or to
vilify a character and I don't think we
need to do that any longer so yeah the
rule with the creation of him was that
it should obey the the makeup should
obey the laws of physics and gravity
whereas before it had been you know a
fairly fit actor in a costume as a
silhouette that's filled with cotton
batting and you're you know your mind
just goes you know I'll pretend I
believe that but you really don't yeah
with this it's seamless it had to be it
would change your gate like your walk
everything about it yeah
that that was born of paying close
attention to documentary footage to
speaking to members of the Obesity
Action Coalition
um and uh observing all of those
sensitivities and and then most
importantly to my to my mind just forget
about all the gear that I was wearing
and just play the scenes connect with my
daughter connect with Hong Chao who's
also nominated for best supporting
actors yeah oh that's awesome
but we have some
Victor which is which is crazy oh look
at that I'm
take I mean that morning four hours oh
my four hours and change so we would get
there very early but don't feel sad for
me because I do Adrian Moreau had to get
there before me and he was always the
last boots to leave at the end of the
day there I am sleeping yes it's
probably like about six o'clock in the
morning now they woke me up someone gave
me a smoothie
um someone give me it's like so quick
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Applause]
guys I'm going